the grinch hated christmas the whole
christmas season oh please don't ask why
no one quite knows the reason
this is a line from the original book so
i dug through the pages to give it a
look and wouldn't you know i came to a
theory for
why the grinch may not be so cheery it
isn't his shoes or some weird tradition
it all boils down to a pre-existing
condition
so cozy up for a holiday tale you love
most
about a medical problem that went
undiagnosed
hello internet welcome to film theory
the show that's as cuddly as a cactus
and as charming as an eel so
like a lot of people i decided to start
the first week of december by kicking my
feet up opening netflix and watching the
2018 version of the dr
seuss christmas classic how the grinch
stole christmas
actually gave me a few ideas for a
really interesting theory but when i
went back to re-watch the movie just
a few days later it was gone completely
removed from netflix us
as of december 4th and i gotta say
really
really taken a christmas movie off the
most popular streaming service during
the first week of december
right before the time of year when
everyone wants to stream it demotion
picture companies
really think that they're going to be
able to squeeze an extra 3.99 out of me
by taking the movie off the service
right at the start of december because
if so
well they were right but i had to call
them all out just to let you all know
who the real grinches are this december
anyway we're here today to talk about
everyone's favorite christmas villain
except is he a villain
really and i'm not just doing the whole
film theory the villain isn't the
villain thing i am asking this sincerely
because if you look at how the
characters introduced in the first five
minutes of the 2018 movie we're shown
that by december 20th he is sick of
hearing nothing but christmas music on
the radio
think i've been there he's a real grumpy
pants in the morning who absolutely
needs his morning coffee hmm
that sounds familiar and he relies on
way too much cake to get him through his
sad moments during the holidays
how much emotional eating have i been
doing my scale can verify that that
one's true
just saying they could not have made the
grinch any more
hashtag relatable the sympathy for the
grinch has drilled home even
more in the 2000 version of the movie
with jim carrey where the grinch's
entire backstory is that he was bullied
as a kid for looking different
you're eight years old and you have a
beard and when the teacher sees what's
going
on she just laughs along with the
bullies teacher of the year everyone
this
predictably leads him to lash out
destroy christmas decorations and
declare that he hates christmas and then
he leaves town and heads out to the
mountains to live in a self-imposed
exile for the next several
decades of his life i hate christmas
i hate it and that was the last time we
ever saw him
look it's easy to look at the grinch and
say huh he's not the most pleasant guy
in whoville but i think by comparison he
might actually be the most pleasant guy
in whoville considering that nobody else
in the town had any sort of compassion
to think that maybe just
maybe it might be worth forming a search
party to go out and find the
eight-year-old child who
wandered off into the snowy mountains
alone
what a rant now of course these are all
the modern portrayals the grinch was
actually a lot meaner in the classic
1966 cartoon and the 1957 dr seuss book
that it's based on
and what we're told in this classic
version is that no one quite
knows the reason for why the grinch is
so mean the grinch
hated christmas the whole christmas
season oh please don't ask why no one
quite knows the reason
and while the story then goes on to
offer several working theories like the
fact that his shoes were too tight or
that his head wasn't screwed on just
right or that his heart was too small
the grinch himself
actually gives us a pretty
all those straightforward girls and boys
will wait bright and early they'll rush
for their toys and then
all that noise oh the noise noise
noise noise there's one thing i hate
all the noise nice nice
so today what i want to prove is that
the grinch is kind of right
that contrary to the story is placing
the blame on him or some
unknown reason we in actuality know why
the grinch hates christmas and it is a
valid
undiagnosed medical condition that he
has to deal with every christmas season
now before we get any further i think
it's important to go back to the
original 1966 cartoon just to remember
the extent of the who's noise making
this isn't a case of someone's kid
learning to play the recorder for the
first time oh no the who's
instruments of choice include things
like the gar ginker and the who hoobler
which create this awful din that sounds
a lot like this
of course between the flu floovers and
the blum bloopers the one that takes the
cake for the most obnoxious musical
abomination is the great big
electro hucario schnook which seems
designed to drive
any person to the brink of sanity
so when the grinch describes the noise
as ear splitting i'm inclined to believe
him
also what's up with the conductor on the
electro who carnio schnook just standing
directly in front of the giant horn his
hearing is probably
shot by now maybe that's why he's
standing there blissfully oblivious of
how wretched the sound is
speaking of sounds while the electro who
carnio schnook might be a miserable
sound to listen to you know what a good
one is that sweet click of the subscribe
button
that ring of the notification bell give
the gift that keeps on giving this
holiday season and subscribe to film
theory if for nothing else then to push
us over the 10 million subscriber mark
that would be the gift that keeps on
giving to us at team theorists and also
to you as you're notified every single
week of the cool interesting thoughtful
episodes that we have coming your way
also let us know down in the comments
below did you ever play an instrument
growing up just curious anyway because
these are mega-sized instruments and
there seem to be a lot of them floating
around on christmas day in whoville
we're gonna assume that they're roughly
as loud as a marching band or about a
hundred decibels of noise of course the
sound that the grinch hates the most is
the outdoor medleys composed of who
voices and ringing church bells
and then they'll do something i hate
most of all
stand close together with
christmas bells ringing the ringing
bells are actually worth taking note of
because one of the main purposes of
church bells in ye olden days was to
inform people of the time
across long distances in fact in the
middle ages before the invention of
pocket watches
bells were the way that people kept
track of time as for why it was church
bells that were ringing well it's mostly
explained by the fact that the church
was the main reason you needed to be
aware of the time farm laborers who back
in the middle ages was about 90
of people could time the start and end
of their days based on when the sun rose
and set but in the catholic tradition
there were certain religious devotions
that were said at certain times of the
day
given that church bells were in many
cases designed so people would be able
to hear them even when they were miles
away working in the field
they were designed to be loud reaching
volumes as high as 110 to 120 decibels
that's around the same volume as a jet
engine in fact in modern times most
countries have actually passed laws
outlawing church bells from being as
loud as they were back in ye olden days
it's also worth noting that decibel
levels follow a logarithmic scale which
means that a noise level being 10
decibels higher
actually translates to it being 10 times
more intense
so an old school church bell ringing at
a volume of 120 decibels is actually
a hundred times the marching band volume
that we just talked about and
a hundred thousand times more intense
than what is legally allowed in certain
european countries nowadays
so let's assume that we have ourselves a
hundred decibels of horns drums and
honking combined with
another 120 decibels of bells maybe the
grinch isn't the one being so
unreasonable here when he complains
about the noise
that the hoos are making but to know for
sure we actually have to calculate how
far the grinch's lair is from whoville
the grinch lives up in mount crumpet and
because we're not really shown
concretely how far the grinch is from
whoville we have to do a bit of
guesswork
during the sledding scene at the end of
the movie which lasts a surprisingly
long time
the grinch sleds downhill for a total
time of 75 seconds to convert that time
into distance all we need is an estimate
for his speed and rather than relying on
pixel measurements i think it's best
that we go with some real world research
researchers at the university of
rochester medical center did a study
that investigated the topic of
average sled speed and found that the
average sled travels at a velocity of 19
miles an hour or
47 kilometers an hour so taking that
information we can find that the
grinch's cave is in fact
actually quite close to whoville he's a
mere 0.4 miles or 0.64 kilometers away
from the town square
because sound decreases in intensity the
further from the source that you are we
can actually use this information to
calculate how loud the bands and bells
would actually be
to the grinch in his cave if the church
bells used by the hoos have an intensity
of about 120 decibels then the grinch is
going to be hearing them at a volume of
61.9 decibels that's somewhere between
normal human speaking volume and the
volume of traffic
strange it's um it's not as loud as i
was actually hoping for
sure it's gonna be noticeable like he's
certainly gonna be able to hear what's
happening down in whoville but it really
shouldn't be enough to make someone fly
off the handle the way that we see the
grinch reacting in the movie or at least
it's not enough to make most people
react that way and most is not all
you see i believe based on all of this
information that we just calculated as
well as what's told to us in the story
itself that the grinch
suffers from a medical condition known
as misophonia
also called selective sound sensitivity
syndrome this
is an actual medical condition that
causes certain sounds to trigger
physiological responses manifesting as
disgust or anxiety in mild cases
or panic fear and extreme anger in more
severe cases what's interesting is that
misophonia has less to do with how loud
certain sounds are and more to do with
the kinds of sounds they are
usually being triggered by specific
sounds common mesophonic sounds include
noises related to eating
things like slurping soup or chewing
loudly or repetitive noises like the
squeaky sound of a car's windshield
wiper blades
it actually happens that my partner
stephanie has misophonia and could
provide a firsthand account of what it's
like to actually experience this for her
the sounds that trigger a physiological
response are eating noises or other
wet mouth sounds she's particularly
sensitive to open mouth eaters because
you can hear
all the gnashing and wet smooshing
sounds that the food is making across
the teeth and tongue she's also
sensitive to dogs and cats grooming
because again
wet tongue sounds and when it gets
triggered i mean
let me just say as an outside observer
there is definitely an extreme
emotional response but i'll let her
describe it i've had this sensitivity
since i was
8 or 10 years old starting with my
parents eating sounds
they're both loud eaters and i noticed
that i was
really really bothered by the way that
they ate pretty much all the time
at first it's just an impulse to cover
your ears
like you're just hearing something
really unpleasant you feel yourself
just kind of wincing to get away from
the sound i spent a lot of time asking
to play music during dinner the tv
anything to drown out the sound of
eating if the sound doesn't go away you
don't get used to it it actually gets
worse
and your feelings go from sort of being
annoyed to at least for me
feeling panicked and angry it all
happens really quickly
and even like pushing through with a lot
of willpower trying to distract yourself
nothing seems to make it better it's
almost like you can't not hear it no
matter what you do
it's like very hard to describe how fast
and how intensely angry
i get when i actually can't get away
from those sounds and i'm like a pretty
even keeled person usually i think
you've asked most of our team like i'm
not
someone who like flies off the handle i
used to leave the table as fast as i
could to get away from sounds when i was
little
um feeling like i was actually like on
the verge of crying or
on the verge of screaming even worse
because it was so
unbearable i know that sounds crazy the
reason i didn't talk about it for
literally decades was because i assumed
it was just something i was imagining
like maybe it was something that was
wrong with me
i also thought maybe i was just like an
angry teenager who was angry with my
parents or something but
it wasn't just my parents it showed up
with other people
in other situations always the same
sounds always eating
always those like gross slurping
teethy tongue sounds just at the
absolute worst
and i learned finally after i had gone
all the way through school and all the
way through college that it had a name
and that it was misophonia and that i
was
not actually the only one to have this
and it was a
huge relief i felt like i had kept this
thing a secret for
like most of my life but to learn that
other people had it was actually
great misophonia isn't fully understood
at this point the idea was first
discovered in 2000
meaning that there still isn't a very
large body of research into the causes
but many researchers believe that our
brains are naturally wired to filter out
or ignore repetitive background noises
but people with misophonia have brains
that are just naturally wired in a way
that doesn't let them ignore
those sounds however based on what we do
know about misophonia the grinch
seems to have a textbook case of it if
severe cases of misophonia trigger
anger or distress well tell me if it
seems like the grinch is suffering from
a case of that
all that is nice
consider also that a lot of the noises
that seem to bother the grinch are
repetitive a paddleball toy
with a repeated knocking sound
repetitive beating of drums
a constant ringing of bells all of it
falling into the pattern of repetitive
sounds that would trigger
a mesophonic response this could also be
further exacerbated by the fact that
when we look down at whoville it appears
to be situated in a caldera land
formation a caldera is a hollow dip
that's found near the tops of some
mountains after volcanic eruptions
leaving behind
an empty bowl-like shape the reason it's
relevant here is that the walls of the
caldera could cause the noises in
whoville to echo
after all an echo is nothing more than a
sound being reflected off a wall or some
other surface so if you needed another
reason to feel sorry for the grinch
maybe add
a hearing disorder to the list if we
look at all the symptoms of misophonia
like having a physiological overreaction
to sound and being triggered
specifically by repetitive sound
everything seems to line up as for me
the only sound this holiday season that
seems to trigger a negative
physiological response is the sound
of silence that silence not being filled
with the clicking of the subscribe
button and the ringing of the
notification bell screw those church
bells
those my friends are the best bells in
all the land all right enough shelling
but hey it's all just a theory a
film theory and cut
[Music]
bye